FBI director James Comey gave about four
hours of testimony yesterday most of it
was related to the investigation into
Donald Trump and Russia although it
lacked specificity in many cases some
interesting things we learn from James
Comey
testimony number one obviously in case
you didn't know or you weren't sure the
FBI is still investigating ties between
the Trump campaign and Russia number two
Senator Lindsey Graham directly asked or
actually as part of number one one of
the people who asked about this was
Senator Lindsey Graham who said is the
investigation still going on Comey
responded simply yes then acting
Attorney General Sally Yates we now have
learned alerted James Comey that
disgraced Trump national security
adviser Michael Flynn had lied about his
conversations with the Russian
ambassador and could be vulnerable to
blackmail that is a really big deal it
relates to the controversy around the
testimony of Yates herself but it also
relates to how early was it at least
hypothesized that Michael Flynn is a guy
who could have problems surrounding him
call it baggage call it toxicity call it
what you want
further James Comey was asked is Russia
still now actively trying to influence
American politics the answer was yes
from James Comey and even though it kind
of shouldn't have been a major deal
Comey said that what influenced him to
go public with the investigation into
Hillary Clinton's emails was that Bill
Clinton met with then Attorney General
Loretta Lynch and Comey felt he had to
go out there and prove that the FBI was
independent from political influence
disaster disaster we talked before Pat
about how this meeting between Loretta
Lynch and Bill Clinton it really should
not have been a big deal but whatever
whatever level of a deal it should have
been it is a big deal because Comey said
that's why he felt he had to go out and
say something to try to assert the FBI's
independence but when he went to the
White House the Obama
white house in July to talk about the
Trump Russia investigation and ask if
they should go forward and public about
that and the Obama White House said no
maybe he should have kept consistent at
that point and not talked about Hillary
Clinton's email situation as well I want
to talk about that consistency because
that's a really really big deal a couple
other things from this hearing James
Comey said that the Justice Department
will be going after leakers to try to
stop leaks Comey said that he doesn't
care what Donald Trump says about him
just before commis testimony late
Tuesday night Donald Trump tweeted quote
FBI director Comey was the best thing
that ever happened to Hillary Clinton in
that he gave her a free Pratt free pass
for many bad deeds Comey brushed it off
during this testimony saying he didn't
give Hillary Clinton a feed a free pass
and then we really got to the pit the
bit of this that made serious headlines
which is when it was proposed to James
Comey that his decision to go public
about the Hillary Clinton investigation
prior to the election but not to go
public about the donald trump russia
investigation prior to the election may
have influenced the outcome of the
election Comey said he felt mildly
nauseous this is a terrible it makes me
mildly nauseous to think that we might
have had some impact on the election but
honestly it wouldn't change the decision
everybody who disagrees with me has to
come back to October 28th of me and
stare at this and tell me what you would
do would you speak or would you conceal
and I could be wrong but we honestly
made a decision between those two
choices that even in hindsight and this
has been one of the world's most painful
experiences I would make the same
decision I like that the this decision
that he made which could have completely
thrown off the course of the United
States of America through the election
of Donald Trump the fact that he might
have had a role in influencing the
outcome
it made him mildly nauseous and the
thing is that people would criticize him
for concealing the Hillary Clinton
investigation but those critiques would
be flaccid in the sense that he was also
not publicly talking about the donald
trump investigation that's what I want
to deal with next right California
Senator Dianne Feinstein during the
hearing asked Comey why did you treat
the investigation so quote dramatically
differently okay and James Comey said I
didn't treat them differently
he said the FBI can
firmed that there was an investigation
into Hillary Clinton's emails and said
no more until the investigation was
closed and similarly Comey said we
revealed that there's an investigation
into Russian efforts to influence the
election of Donald Trump months after
that elect investigation was opened and
were only going to talk about it again
once it's been closed of course the key
difference is yes eventually James Comey
admitted to the existence of both
investigations both investigations were
taking place before the election but
only one of the investigations was
mentioned before the election as I was
watching Comey say this I was I was
laughing or crying I don't know which
one is it listen I did the same thing we
did two investigations and I mentioned
two investigations yes but one of those
investigations you mentioned after Trump
had already been elected that is not
exactly treating the situations the same
way I think he is an honorable man in
his serving a decent job as FB either I
do over hosting uh but he made the wrong
decision here you so you don't believe
that and you know what I have to I have
to say I actually don't know that what
he did was ideologically motivated that
doesn't mean that there were no that
there was no foul play in the forces
that may have ultimately influenced
James Comey to announce the Hillary
Clinton investigation before the
election and the Trump investigation
only after the election but I am getting
the sense from this testimony that he
was not personally ideological sort of
that he was I don't want to necessarily
use the term bamboozled but that he was
manipulated into mentioning one
investigation before and the only the
other one only after yeah there's
definitely conflicting things here we
know that James Comey is also a
Republican but it seems like both
parties at some point or another have
criticized him for giving preferential
treatment to one side
long story short that explanation from
Comey that hey we treated them the same
way because we mentioned both
investigations November 8th and whether
you did it before or after has a pretty
big role to play and whether you treated
these situations the same way